lights cameras action can a two-week
celebration of cinema after a bruising
two years for the big screen 35 000 film
buyers and sellers critics and
celebrities are gathering to do business
and promote all genres of film the
festival is opening with the french
comedy final cut a love letter to
filmmaking and budget zombie movies from
the team behind the oscar winner the
artist
the film's cast and crew walked the red
carpet earlier to the flash of bulbs and
the cheers from fans but it's actually
ukraine that's going to be pulling focus
this year every door has been opened for
their delegations and there's lots of
discussion here about how filmmakers can
help the ukraine's film industry rebuild
itself post-war meanwhile official
russian delegations have been banned
from attending the first to appear on
the screen was actually president
zielenski himself
hate will end by disappearing and the
dictators will die
finally we must win we need cinema to
guarantee this ending that each time it
will be on the side of freedom
and as it has always been it will be
above all the path of cinema
an all-star jury will consider the 21
competing films and pick a winner for
the palm door prize a prize that can
propel a relatively obscure production
into the mainstream but with only five
films directed by women i put forward
the perennial question of diversity this
is a question for rebecca hall as an
actor and director do you think the
festival is doing enough to address
gender equality and racial diversity
with this lineup this year the way that
we are addressing this the way that we
are dealing with these things
needs to be addressed on a grassroots
level as well it's not just
you know the festivals the public-facing
situations it's also about crews it's
also about
all the minutiae of what goes into the
industry at large and a lot of that is
to do with education outreach help to
get people who don't have access to
those
doors in
has been called a cathedral dedicated to
world cinema this year films from japan
south korea and iran are keenly
anticipated by critics no films from
sub-saharan africa have been selected in
any category but that hasn't dampened
spirits founder of the africa pavilion
says filmmakers from the continent have
a unique set of skills i think they are
very good at doing a lot with little and
it makes that the creativity is at its
best
so we don't count on the festival to say
your film is great
the film festival is leaning on
blockbusters like the new top gun movie
to draw the media's attention but it is
art house cinema it seeks to champion
between the explosion of streaming
services and the closure of cinema
theaters it needs all the attention it
can get charlie angela al jazeera can